so while doing research i i rewatched
hundreds of
films and uh based on what came up in
our interviews
um and no one had ever mentioned he's
the spider woman
but william hurt's character always read
to me as trans
it's an accident if i had the courage
i'd cut it off
you'd still be a man a man
that was all i needed to hear to confirm
my suspicions you know and it was a
really painful moment to witness
and it but it makes you really wonder if
a trans audience was ever considered
when you are a member of a marginalized
community
most of the film and television is not
made
with you in mind and so if you are a
person of color
an lgbtq person a person who's an
immigrant um
a person with a disability you develop a
critical awareness because you
understand that the images that you're
seeing are not your life
forgive me papa
wait so this next moment um is the first
story
where that laverne shared with me during
our first meeting in june 2017 right the
film yentl came up and i told her that i
wasn't going to
use it in disclosure because the
character is so clearly not trans
and then laverne sat back and quietly
said that she really identified with
barbra streisand's character as yentl
and i joked with her saying that it must
be because of her fondness for jewish
men
but i couldn't have been more wrong i
giggle because it's like i'm a black
trans girl from alabama and like i live
for yentl
um i don't know if i'm the target
audience for
free angel
i was really young when i thought it
embodied so many of my longings to be
seen for who i was but needing to fit in
in a traditional way
to sort of get by at the time i mean the
song will someone ever look at me that
way was like my jam
the yentle story is so indicative of
laverne's specific lens
as a trans woman right finding those
personal stories really became the heart
of the film
so it's like shaping and structuring the
narrative was a puzzle and we decided to
base it on these
personal memories and experiences as
opposed to a structure that was
chronological or thematic
so this really allowed the film to
unfold
as an emotional experience inviting a
personal connection with our cast right
all of whom are transgender people
the vern's story shows the power of
hollywood storytelling
and and the ways in which trans people
find themselves in films that
never had them in mind right so having
this trust and access to our cast was so
key
in getting these moments right and
finding these moments and part of that
trust
came from having so many trans people on
set we prioritized hiring trans people
and when we couldn't do that we mentored
trans people and
our cast felt safe enough to be
vulnerable and
share what it was like to identify with
images that were
often excluding them right or negating
their existence and
you know yentl is not a trans character
we can all agree on that the story is
about someone
pretending to be someone they're not you
know and that is just like laverne had
to pretend
to be a boy in order to get by as a
child i connected to that because i was
a girl that
no one saw as a girl at the time
and now someone has looked at me that
way
and also victor victoria a woman
pretending to be a man pretending to be
a woman
ridiculous it's preposterous in fact
it's so preposterous no one would ever
believe it
in 1982 i graduated from high school and
that was the year yentl came out
victor victoria came out when you played
me and i saw those movies so many times
[Music]
it's a guy nick adams has worked at glad
for over 20 years i i
he's the director of transgender
representation and i'm not sure anyone
else in the world knows more about the
topic that he does
and he recently admitted to me that he
did not believe we'd be able to pull off
making the film
because it seemed like too daunting of a
task
for whatever reason we are creatures who
want to see our stories reflected back
to us
starting with cave paintings to 3d imacs
we want to see ourselves reflected back
to us in a story
towards the end of disclosure yancy ford
quotes marianne wright element
saying children cannot be what they
cannot see and he continues to say that
it's not just about children right it's
about all of us we can't be a better
society
until we see a better society i can't be
in the world until i see
that i am in the world you know and this
idea points directly back to an earlier
scene in the film where yancey talks
about seeing
gender transgressive images in early
film but also has to contend
with dw griffith directing those films
one of the films that is often credited
with
inventing what's called the dynamic
montage
and i was a dw griffith film this
history has never been documented before
i spent the first three years focused
entirely on research curating and
harnessing a mountain
of archival footage of over a thousand
film and television clips right in order
to frame all the personal anecdotes that
people shared
and by juxtaposing different emotions
we're able to move the film away from a
survey film and into an emotional
narrative
susan susan striker is one of the
leading if not the leading trans
historian of our time and for disclosure
i think we spent god like two days on
the phone probably about 12 hours
and the story of judith of bethulia
truly blew my mind like here
was a character in 1914 who by today's
definition is trans right here we
finally can see ourselves in early
cinema
and this is proof we've always been a
site of fascination and therefore part
of society
you know and after that phone call with
susan i found the film on youtube
and it was a horrendous copy like you
could barely make out the images but i
didn't care
like i kept it in the film i thought it
was so important and such a vital part
of the story
thankfully my editor did care and
eventually we found a beautiful copy
it's like trans and cinema have grown up
together it's like
we have always been presence on screen
and it's not just coincidental i mean
there's something really
deeply connected it was so interesting
albeit not surprising to see the
intersection of racism and transphobia
dating all the way back
to early cinema can we all just talk
about dw griffith for a minute
[Music]
as the missy elliott song would say we
need to just back it up for a minute
the fact that we study and teach
dw griffith without saying a word
about the representation like i'm glad
i didn't go to film school because if i
had seen
birth of a nation when they got to that
blackface moment
when this guy springs up from behind a
bush wanting to rape the white woman
that would have been it for me at film
school right that would have been my
last day
not only is dw griffith incredibly
racist
but he understands that you can
turn gender non-conforming people
into the joke of your story it was
really meaningful and exciting to learn
about the twin fascinations of gender
transgression and race and how they
played out and screen
reflecting the anxieties of the time
but it was equally necessary to
acknowledge dw's racist legacy
and hold historians accountable to that
and reckoning with conflicting feelings
became a huge theme throughout the
entire film
it's like oh yeah great d.w griffith you
you know racist piece of [ __ ] you you've
invented the stereotype in film well
done
[Music]